c'est à l'hyper viau et j'accueille
estelle halliday madame m
c'est ce qu'annoncé
les secrétaires dans les très fiers de
vous avoir en plus machine cette semaine
à la radio à il était une bonne maman je
suis ravi parce que je savais très bien
j'ai l'impression d'être en famille bâle
alors regardez bien entre estelle et moi
il ya un point commun
mes yeux faut chercher un faux faut bien
chercher il ya un point commun entre
estelle halliday et moi non je ne trouve
pas nous sommes tous les deux de seine
maritime
ah oui estelle et de tôtes voilà et moi
je suis du havre donc voilà on est
normand je sais que si ça pour la
rassurer je la met à l'aise
il ya une autre façon de mettre et c'est
là l'idée à l'aise c'est de lui dire ce
qui est vrai qu'un sondage l'a classé
parmi les trois plus belle femme de
france avec catherine deneuve et
isabelle adjani et en plus vous avez
réussi
josé garcia est arrivé à passer de la
télé au cinéma avec un certain succès et
vous vous êtes arrivé à passer du
mannequinat à la télé avec aussi
beaucoup de succès donc c'est plutôt
bien
votre mariage est réussi on joue pas
très bien ce qu'on peut vous dire parce
que vous êtes un couple heureux et vous
savez que demain enfin pendant
l'émission ça on va passer au printemps
on va être le 21 mars
donc voilà on voulait célébrer l'amour
je vais 1 c'est surtout qu'on voudrait
foutent la merde dans le trouvez comment
bon alors vous êtes né à tôtes comme le
disait à dos entre rouen et dieppe
voilà vous faire un plan je connais très
bien et c'est marie très bien votre père
qui avait là évidemment vous mitrailler
sans cesse en disant vous allez être un
top model et quand vous avez été top
model a dit j'ai toujours su que tu
allais faire ce métier là jamais dit ah
bon vous avez une enfance assez normal
finalement parce que maintenant vous
fréquentez les grands de ce monde mais
je lisais dans un magazine que quand
vous aviez 16 ans avec votre petite amie
de l'époque parce que on nous avait
quand même eu des petits amis avant
david
normal donc à l'époque avec sa petite
amie dont je ne citerai pas le prénom
parce que comme vous avez pu le
remarquer on est très très discret dans
cette émission j'ai dit cache pas que ce
soit avec son comptoir et des photos
avec son petit ami vous vendiez des
habits des fripes sur les marchés de
c'est vrai dans les banlieues ouvrières
de rouen mais c'est vrai oui oui bon
c'est vrai c'est une petite expérience
que j'ai fait c'est sympathique déjà
dans les vêtements finalement elle
partie des gens les vêtements alors vos
parents étaient été assez d'accord que
vous fréquentiez ce garçon à condition
vous passiez le bac avant de fréquenter
ou 1 1 les parents étaient d'accord que
tu est elle présente le garçon à la
condition qu'elle passe bien son baquet
ce qu'elle a fait d'ailleurs et à
condition qu'elle habite au dessus du
magasin avec le garçon c'est vrai oui
c'est fin c'est moi qui t'ai de la
région je savais pas ça
moi je suis désolé j'ai appelé à rouen
j'ai tout le monde a raconté sa non à
tout ce que je dis c'est je vais lui
dans des magazines jeunes évidemment pas
pas inventé il va beaucoup chez le
dentiste regarder ses dents à bon mais
ça c'est vrai que vous habitiez au
dessus du salon de coiffure et alors là
on en arrive à un point important c'est
comment vous êtes rentré dans la photo
c'est à dire qu'un jour vous rencontrez
boulevard sébastopol quelqu'un qui avait
un journal cette les photos revues c'est
ça un âge et il vous dit je veux faire
des photos avec vous et je vous prendre
dans mon agence dans votre agence mais
en agence les gens commençaient avec
photos revues oui mais non parce qu'en
fait la première fois j'avais 17 ans
quand je l'aï rencontré et c'est là où
ma mère m'a dit non tu passe ton bac et
après tu feras ce que tu veux après
cette partie aux etats unis enfin c'est
pas tout raconter mais c'est aux états
unis faisait bien c'est vrai que ça a
été très très vite
en trois mois je travaillais pour le ls
a commencé en février déjà en juillet
j'avais une première couverture de elle
donc c'est très très rapide dans ce
métier là c'est vrai que ça se passe pas
toujours comme ça et donc vous
réussissez aux états unis et puis un
jour on vous invite de fonctionner mais
je n'y voyais rien
djouhri c'est ma vision est ce qu'on va
un jour vous réussissez ravis de se
demander aux états unis et un julien
henry d'avant non j'en ai même pas la
question la spéciale
dans une émission de tournage et estelle
halliday émission de télé parce que tu
es blanc quand elle est allée paquin et
donc lefébure c'est ça et maintenant je
demande au réalisateur serge khalfon de
nous montrer ce qu'on a vu dans cette
émission de télé débattez une première
année à la marque pour la suite si tu
dois avoir des enfants
je suis très content avec ce que je fais
je me suis toujours en studio je fais
beaucoup musique et c'est toujours ce
que j'ai adoré faire le cycle de fonder
une famille éventuellement plus tard oui
mais c'est compatible
je pense au décor est bien placé pour le
savoir
mais pour l'instant c'est pas vraiment
c'est pas vraiment le but je pense que
profond des familles il faut d'abord
être il faut d'abord avoir un métier je
pense que pour l'instant je suis juste
entre la transition de d'en avoir un et
c'est pas tout et tout n'est pas acquis
encore donc il faut attendre un petit
peu je pense
[Musique]
oh
voilà ici
j'ai bien étudié votre dossier ne
savaient pas qu'ils y étaient avec
patrick sabatier ça et donc ses dents
les uns et les autres restaient la liste
des grands comptes patrick sébastien est
là il est viré de la télé voilà c'est ça
l'histoire donc vous rencontrer david
alors c'était vous vous dites vous qu'il
avait déclaré mon premier baiser je les
données à l'âge de 12 ans je s'appelait
stéphane il avait les yeux bleus les
cheveux blonds ensuite j'ai eu quelques
petits amis mais j'ai jamais fapi
lyonnais mais je rêvais du grand amour
pour ça vous êtes là ce soir à cause du
printemps avec l'âge j'ai rencontré
david
non mais c'est beaucoup moins cher les
coûts de foule se met arriver aussi
quand j'ai rencontré david j'ai senti
qu'il pourrait devenir mon mari c'est
fou tout de suite dans les yeux malgré
la chanson non c'est vrai tout de suite
vous tout de suite oui on s'est vus dans
les escaliers ça a été levée par les
défis qui vous fascine parce que josé à
6 mais moi je trouve ça jamais arrivé
six 6 mois les femmes elle a su tout de
suite bout mais la venue sur moi y'a
forcément la bienvenue sur vous il a su
tout de suite
non mais c'est ça alors que les filles
ont une espèce de davantage sur nous
c'est qu'elles savent tout de suite quel
est le mec et vont craquer et vous
princesse un mot si tout de suite face à
ça m'arrive souvent tout de suite quoi
voilà madame dhalla
mais l'homme bref princess erika n'est
pas en france évidemment ces dix passent
à la télé mon mari on regarde il va me
battre donc quand vous l'avez rencontré
vous aviez le trac il vous dit bonjour
vous ne répondez pas donc il a crié vous
le seul levier et puis après il sait
tout mais c'est hallucinant il a finir
coursières jamais en tous les cas france
2 france hier seulement
j'aimerais bien qu'on serge en france et
un jour votre ami ruth de votre agence
invite à dîner et là alors ça tombe bien
ça fait c'est carey carey alors vous
pouvez pas lui parler toujours à david
on peut pas lui parler mais regardez
vous rougissez et voilà et là vous
rougissez pas du tout pareil on voit
bien la différence
on voit bien évidente alors ça a été
platonique pendant huit mois
et puis un soir ce sera après il ya un
soir de folie est l étalon dallas
travaillé toute la journée est elle est
fatiguée dans une chambre d'hôtel
raconte tentant ardisson est alors la
vie de l'appel de paris
j'avais dit pas le mettre à côté de là
alors ça c'est donc ils appellent ils
vous appellent david de paris et vous
fait rire bien entendu c'est toujours
comme ça que ça marche il vous fait rire
et vous a fait rire comment que je sache
moi je le sais alors dit oui parce que
sinon je vais le dire il est super
équipe et lui sinon c'est quand on
préfère six interviews soi même on est
mieux les informer c'est pour ça non
mais il vous a fait rire en fait à vous
racontant comment il casser les jouets
que johnny hallyday lui offrait non mais
c'est ça oui c'est ça en partie quand
même parce que c'est quoi un an plus
tard alors à peine un an plus tard ben
non plus tard serge ce matin devant la
petite mairie de freineuse il valait
mieux avoir un escabeau pour voir voir
arriver par exemple s'ils vivent là une
maman qui s'avoue heureux
johnny hallyday un papa accompagné d'une
ravissante brune et enfin les jeunes
mariés à leur sortie de la mairie vient
d'épouser n'py terrible
estelle une normande de 23 ans top
modèle s'appelle marié s'est marié
souvenirs souvenirs c'était le 12 avril
65 les yétis après johnny et sylvie
étaient les idoles des jeunes
les journalistes et en pagne à
l'intérieur des prisons pourrait
imaginer que les choses se sont passées
ainsi
je suis au top 5 ans tuée top model
alors déclamé
[Applaudissements]
ça parlait dans l'est la geste el mahdi
a pas de problème aucun problème à cause
des trois c'est à cause de la règle des
trois c est 3 ses communications
confiance alors voir ce que les jeunes
aient fait là je connaissais la règle
des 4 c et communication confiance
complicité après un cocu qui va passer
les classes et c'est pas pareil
bon maintenant on fait de la télé donc
avec nos amis jérôme revon et stéphane
gâteau donc un samedi soir chez estelle
ça se passe bien non très bien vous avez
combien la dernière fois 26 c'est bien
on applaudit à tourner dans sa part de
marché
m
celle ci ça peut monter à 34 bon
j'arrête parce qu'à moins de 26 mois le
monde bon avant de passer à la suite
jours et qu'on regarde un extrait donc
de samedi soir chez estelle
tout d'abord bon vieux super g c'est
encore un film championne de natation
synchronisée
je recherche a donné des cours de danse
aquatique à de jeunes des faibles
norvégien et essai doit accepter si
désireux de modeler leur corps au fil
des ans
je vous attends des jabots blood in et
robuste imberbe vue de bien entendu si
tu es bras une énorme personnalité
intéresse aussi
c'est un mois avant le week-end
[Applaudissements]
elle est
elle est vachement plus vachement plus
drôle qu'avant roumanoff à tous les gars
donc céder il faut lire une parodie des
petites annonces d'elie semoun et vous
c'est courage et 12 ans les dire comme
ça c'était un cadeau une surprise
le juge non je joue le jeu c'est dans
l'émission justement c'est ce qu'on a
envie de faire d'avoir des petites des
petites choses comme ça un peu
différente c'est très drôle
les autres émissions de variétés et
divertissements type appel bon donc il
faut dire que la prochaine émission et
le 14 avril à ces saintes 17 avril ça
mais vous savez quand c'est vos
émissions sur france 2 oui assez bien
oui c'est en fait en fait mousser le 3
voilà mousser le 3 avril je sais cette
fois à l'air d'un jeune auteur
bon alors en ce moment où tout le monde
parle de vous pour cette histoire
d'internet là
donc je pars à compter la sphère comment
comment vous l'avez vécu comment je vais
pas la raconter non simplement c'est
vrai que il ya deux trois petits points
à mettre au clair c'est que ces photos
ont été étaient d'abord des photos
personnelles
quand vous avez comme un volet j'avais
17 ans enfin bon c'était vraiment c'est
pas du tout et les photos sur la plage
genre en string ou alors sans l'eau face
et des choses j'ai personnel c'est oui
en plus et à manger j'ai l'âge des
jeunes donc c'était pas les photos à but
professionnel on me les a volés et
ensuite elle nous a volé un proche
en plus cela va durer pas le prénom ne
s'ennuie pas de prénoms n'ont eux pas
c'est si oublié mais c'est donc après
elles ont été vendus un magazine que
j'ai attaqué forcément un deuxième
magazine que j'ai encore attaqué ensuite
on les a vues sur internet vous avez
demandé une amende parce que d'abord
vous l'avez demandé au type kiki à ce
serveur internet de données non du type
qui vous à qui vous avez avait mis ses
photos sur internet
et lui n'a pas voulu vous donner donc il
est resté le seul responsable et vous
l'avez attaqué et fait que vous n'êtes
pas la main morte
vous n'êtes pas capable mais c'est pas
moi qui demande ça ce sont les tribunaux
ses clients heureusement voulait verser
parce que ça alors si vous n'aviez pas
fait je vous aurais demandé de le faire
ce soir
heureusement ces quatre cent mille
francs bull est versée à une association
pour les enfants semblaient voilà que tu
l'as
donc à part les enfants même si vous
avez vous même chez bon d'une photo
d'estelle
mettez les sur internet c'est pour
l'enfance maltraitée les oiseaux je
voulais dire moi je propose pour
qu'elles soient tranquilles
oui oui se déshabille ici gistré chez
vous la cassette
as tu vois là on entend depuis les toits
[Musique]
vous à claudie très sincèrement on sait
jamais rencontré 1 et pourtant je vis
avec vous depuis de longues années
je vais vous montrer la photo qui est
dans mon bureau voilà je la montre avec
caméra vous la connaissez voilà voilà
avec quoi je dis moi j'ai pensé arrêter
à la révolution de 1789 et une autre est
allé jusqu'à 68 alors 68 j'avais 19 ans
donc évidemment cohn bendit c'était moi
mon idole absolue
alors mes parents sont dans la salle
aujourd'hui à l'époque il vous aimez
moins que moi mais moi je vous adresse
non non c'est ok nous allons maintenant
et dj s'est calmé alors donc voilà c'est
pour vous dire à quel point on est
heureux de vous avoir parce que je vous
ai toute la journée devant les yeux je
trouve cette photo je leur montre cette
photo est vraiment un symbole
d'insolence absolument incroyable elle
le regarde
ac c'est vraiment l'insolence est résumé
dans cette photo alors vous êtes vous
êtes assez on parle beaucoup de vous en
ce moment on voit beaucoup moins vais
vous dire les écolos ont imposé la
journée sans voitures mais la journée
sans cohn-bendit et moi je sais pourquoi
il est à la mode parce qu'il est vous
les vues sont très à la mode
la fiq est numéro 1 du top 50 elle
s'appelle larusso c'est une route
axelle red est en train d'arriver numéro
un dans les collections c'est pas vous
qui me contredirait y avait beaucoup de
rouge cette année
un edith cresson très à la mode sont
vraiment vous dire mais au fond au fond
il est gentil
alors on va faire un usage des jeunes
générations on va faire quand même après
on va parler de l'actualité on va faire
quand même
on va parler un petit peu un petit peu
de votre vie quoi vos parents sont
arrivés d'allemagne ils sont partis
d'allemagne en 1933
1 ils sont venus en france pour des
raisons plutôt politique parce que votre
père était était de gauche donc il avait
un peu des problèmes évidemment avec le
régime qui dirige l allemagne à cette
époque là ce qui fait que chez vous
d'ailleurs on peut dire vous étiez tous
des juifs allemands ont accepté chez
vous c'était vrai alors vos parents sont
arrivés en france et vous vous êtes né à
montauban
je suis pas les gens vous le saviez vous
non j'ignorais d'une à montauban en fête
et ses parents on peut le dire
mon frère est à montrouge à montrouge et
vous avez fêté vos parents ont fait
l'amour le soir du débarquement
la preuve ils ont fait l'amour peut être
aussi le soir du lit vers son angle mais
ils ont profité de la première
possibilité biologique après le
département de faire un enfant
voilà donc quitte à sauter autant que ce
soit de cette façon là bien sûr et puis
aussi
ce qui veut dire que daniel cohn bendit
était vraiment d'enfants de la liberté
quand on a été conçu au moment du
débarquement
on ne peut qu'aimer on ne peut qu'aimer
la liberté alors on va regarder serge
khalfon si vous voulez on va regarder
quelques quelques photos daniel vous
voyez bien l'écran je vois je vois
combien vous allez nous les commenter
alors voilà ça c'est vous avec votre
frère dans nos frères à 9 ans de plus et
autres c'est déjà le poing levé la wii
c'est déjà le poing levé sur tout le
monde si mon fils est né quand il est
sorti du ventre de sa mère avec le poing
levé aussi le poing levé c'est assez
j'ai 13 ans n'ont peut-être moins moi je
sais pas là c'est dur ça faisait
beaucoup de sport
non oui j'étais arrivé là il est passé
par hec vous à 10h
je vais voir 10 en 2010 au goût ils ont
vraiment non
bon c'est la dernière fois que j'attaque
quelqu'un sur ses problèmes de poids
vous avez des photos les photos on les a
c'est le garçon qui a mis les photos des
stents sur internet si nous les avons dû
laisser un mec à cannes elle a déjà tout
dit on était super il a eu beaucoup
moins cher on voyait encore une photo
que je voudrais voir ça c'est le sait le
premier j'étais sur mon sort j'étais sur
mon premier permis de conduire
quand vous étiez arrêté samedi à ça
c'était une époque difficile
bon alors on me tend à baisser c'est
bien parce quand on voit aujourd'hui
c'est un espoir pour tout le monde
franchement non mais sérieux c'est
vachement bien regarder n'y a pas
beaucoup de différence à un peu et
surtout restez gamin de campagne
électorale je vais débuter tous appuyer
les gamins ça me coupe tout ce qui va
aller voter pour un gamin non mais
sérieux politique et tout on a dit tout
à l'heure à estella l'idée qu'on l'avait
invitée parce que le 21 mars c'était le
printemps et elles forment un couple
parfait comme vous le savez ce qui nous
désole absolument avec david hallyday
alors vous on vous a invité ça peut
s'arranger oui c'est vivre
sur la piste
bon nombre des invités service
management vous invitez parce que bas
après demain c'est le 22 mars et le 22
mars est votre anniversaire puisque tout
a commencé en 68
le 22 mars pas refaire l'histoire de 60
ans ferdinand non parce que sam enfermer
un cache de 68 à tomber mais pourquoi
c'est pour ça qu'on vous aime en énorme
attention basse et pitié ça fait 30 ans
mais justement mais c'est pour ça
maintenant je vais vous dire maintenant
vous voulez d'abord il faut quand même
dire une chose en 68 qui était drôle
c'est que puisque les gens le savent et
la vie a continué à être drôle après 68
oui mais vous quand vous avez vous lu
[ __ ] le le ministre de la jeunesse et
des sports dans la piscine parce que les
gars rigolo rancié ce que vous dites
nous n'avons jamais voulu le mettre dans
la piscine
c'est ce que l'histoire de france ont
dit non l'histoire dit que nous avons
interpellé le ministre parce qu'il a
inauguré une piscine et celle d'ailleurs
plus pourquoi la whey jeu peu importe en
chercher des fonds je pense oui
non mais le problème il est là vous
arrivez directement le problème c'est à
dire qu'en fait je sais pas qui vous a
dit qu'il fallait que vous deveniez à un
type pas parler de 68 devenir un vrai
sérieux un médiateur est plus un
provocateur qui quels instituts de
sondage qui vous a dit ça à personne non
c'est pas ça assez que la prévoir des
fois non des fois des fois c'est vrai
que je provoque mais j'ai l'impression
comme ça qu'on veut mettre dans une cage
ou dit ce type là quoi qu'ils fassent
génétiquement y provoque ou lingettes
d'ayasse eric sorby s'ils s'étaient
tombés dans un grand bassin il était
fort commun comme un buffle
oui moi je suis tombé dans une bassine
oui je suis provocateur quoi que je
fasse mais c'est pas tout à fait ça les
noms mais c'est pour ça qu'on vous aime
si je comprends pas pourquoi vous les
gommer ce côté là je gobe devrait fermer
là dedans moi je trouve ça normal
merci ah oui c'est comme vous avec trop
de blabla non c'est comme toute personne
qui n'a pas envie d'être d'être tu vois
qu'elle a légué seulement bon pour une
action ou un fait et parce qu'au comité
la vie continue et on évolue surtout on
voulait dire que je suis un vieux baba
et que je lui parle de 60 noms mais
énorme pour ce qui l'a saisie
déclaration d'amour elle a raison je
comprends que quelqu'un me dit je t'aime
parce que j'aime 68 ou alors d'accord
oui je suis d'accord mais quelqu'un qui
me dit je te dire faire à 69
aïe moi je trouve que le monde est
moderne et que je t'aime bien faire un
ouais on disait ça il ya 30 ans à la
télé tu passais plus jamais jamais mais
si on fera un grand grande manif on va
voir ce que sont devenus vos amis de 68
vous les voyez la jeunesse marc
sauvageau tout ça mais on n'est pas la
génération verdun ouais on fait qu on
essaie on n'a pas fait la guerre de 14
600 exactement quand même et c'est nord
est justement
donc j'ai des amis j'ai des amis de
l'époque il y en a mais c'est pas parce
que j'étais à la télévision avec un âge
et ce marais avec son banjo jacques way
qu'on était d'aider grand copain on
avait des des rôles différents
mémé kouchner vous êtes resté copains
quand même mais je les ai connus après
un bond à corps ou alors on va mettre ça
c'est toujours utile
hôtel
m
[Applaudissements]
moi
[Musique]
et
à
oh
hossa
on ne sait pas
[Applaudissements]
ça
aux mauvaises nouvelles se sont tous
avec johnny à oui avec johnny il avait
fait la marseillaise il a fait le chant
des partisans
donc avec johnny la marseillaise ça
serait pas mal pourquoi pas être vos
murs en tout cas bah oui mais là c'était
pour mes 50 50 ans absolument
bon alors en 87 vous avez tenté une
carrière est bien fait d'aller vers le
cinéma
ah ouais magnéto ccva je l'aï fait ces
paris est vraiment méchant alors je me
suis pas trompé sa marque pour toi sur
l'autre plein charih je suis content
pour toi
il ya une belle scène comme il n'a pas
pris la meilleure vague comparer bel
avenir
non non non ah bah oui ça c'est le
risque qu'a pis c'est loin et houston je
m'écris là ça serait de voir cet été
ouais bien sûr merzak allouache merzak
allouache il ya une très belle scène
n'en est qu'une deux mois dans l aile et
les deux jeunes contre est bien allé
très très bien je veux dire pardon je
peux pas accepter c'est que c'est
valérie kaprisky c'est pour le voyage
t'en fais pas pour le disque georges
n'enverrait à ta mère maintenant mais
ton pull jeté mais le métro c'est
effectivement je montre la cachette
parce que si chez vous si vous voulez
acheter ce film donc c'est un lit et
marie donc c'est un amour à paris de
mère aka loiret caille cascadeur ah
ouais faut en vidant la vouvoie dans des
cascades
c'est vraiment ce final oui c'est un
fait atterri c'est un film formidable je
le conseille il n'a pas vu là il est
même un vin chaud llaves ont rien montré
une minute et demie et fait comme si les
faits que les critiques de cinéma qui
n'ont pas vu un film mais qui n'aime pas
les acteurs on va pas tuer les noirs on
va pas non plus envers des atouts regard
des normes a bien sûr mais c'est pas la
peine moi j'entre et non plus à faire
quelques autres qui parlent des films
sans les avoir vus non ce que je voulais
dire sérieusement quand vous regardiez
l'extrait là vous vous disiez ça c'est
le côté tapis quoi c'est l'effet tapie
vous à vous avez peur d'être assimilé à
tapis maintenant c'est l'effet un peu
qu'à un moment on essaie de toucher à
tout et que des fois si on est président
d'un club de foot n'a pas besoin de
faire de deux politiques et si on fait
de la politique on n'a pas besoin de
faire un cinéma c'est cette critique là
d'accord c'est ce qu'on disait non
tapisser les piles tapis seul football
tapisser la télévision tapis c'est la
politique tapissait par tous bords dont
on en arrive
en france on en arrive aujourd'hui donc
aujourd'hui vous êtes tête de liste donc
des verts et vous avez déclaré
aujourd'hui vous avez déclaré en parlant
des verts je veux les sortir de leurs
gonds schisme gnangnan fait c'était il
ya quatre ans alors il faut faire les
notes
moi j'étais j'ai fait cette déclaration
quand les verts n'avaient pas encore
décidé de ce ancré à gauche c'était le
temps du ni ni à 7 et vestiaire et tout
ça voilà
olala donc justement est donc d'accord
alors la médaille d'or
voilà là ou bien c'est bon alors vous
venez de lui dominique voynet
et puis surtout c'est vraiment elle dit
elle dit en parlant de vous il est
fascinant il est émouvant et il est
d'autant plus dangereux qu'on ne se
laisseraient avoir par un tel talent
elle a dit ça oui et alors se méfier de
vous l'a quand même apparemment non je
crois qu'elle est sincère elle le
ressens comme ça et je trouve que au
lieu de jouer elle dit on a envie de
faire une campagne ensemble et mais
quand bon elle a cette sincérité de dire
quand je le vois à la télé je me disais
fois tiens attention il a quelque chose
elle passe bien en télé ça c'est vrai
oui puis d'un autre côté qui dérange
pour me le dit moi je trouve ça
vachement sympa vous savez quoi
elle devrait se faire teindre les
cheveux en roux je sais qu'elle a changé
de couleur
mais elle change de couleur tout fait
seul vrai qu'elle se baignent à la
régulière
alors on a un document là vous allez
voir un document vous êtes avec
dominique voynet
magnéto
c'est karl zéro
le vent souffle sur la scène les
élections européennes la provocation il
faut dire que c'est mon domaine
dominique voynet est venu me chercher
les verts ont décidé de mener ce combat
pour le gagner pour vaincre le bc
krivine et la grille et lors de la
grande bataille a désormais sonné à moi
maintenant de défendre notre terre
contre une armée de communisme et a
croisé le fer pour prendre les électeurs
dont ils se croient propriétaires
j'exige d'être en deux heures et la
sortie du nucléaire je vends le second
des sans papiers c'est vrai je fais du
zèle
dominique me donne le soir dégorger plus
gros mais pour que je trouve la force de
contredire ionel et pour piquer les
blast d'hommes et de noël ce n'est pas
la première fois pour moi que je bats
rumba j'espère en être digne et parc
planté son foulard
[Musique]
dans
oh
il a
il
j'ai cru en eux
m
il a ni dans
deschamps 2
écolo
[Musique]
la tribu totani pire ton numéro deux aux
européennes est-ce que vous allez voter
pour les verts aux européennes
c'est vrai que si j'avais voté j'aurais
voté pour toi je ne vote pas parce que
d'abord je suis pas encore inscrit son
avis je suis très mauvais citoyens
et puis en fait je me sens jacques tu
devenu votre part inscrivez-vous en fin
mais ça c'est incroyable parce qu'il ya
des pays où on est automatiquement
inscrits dans cette histoire d'aller
s'inscrire ou un mois déjà je trouve ça
rébarbative et en plus tu peux citer six
mois s'il me prend l'envié d'aller à ce
qu'est ce qu'un jour le 13 juin le droit
d'y aller très loin et j'irai avec mon
passeport ils ont intérêt à prendre mon
beau temps oui surtout si c'est pour moi
en lisant manif leur a dit que le vin le
13 juin juin il dit pas ce jeu il dit
joint
c'est pas les jouets bijoux est une
déformation profession alors est-ce que
vous voteriez pour daniel cohn-bendit
bien sûr rappelle moi moi j'avais une
petite question juste à vous poser comme
le nombre d'années
vous êtes allé toujours au front que ça
soit crs en face où je sais pas je serai
sa gmao macha est-ce que vous avez pris
beaucoup que vous était hyper proches
même la photo ici vous alors mais il est
là le téléphone du dentiste il a 73 ans
à oui ça pourrait avoir des contrats il
est fort ben non mais le truc c'est
quand tu te tu t'approches tout seul
un flic tu prends jamais ce que ça et 6
y attend pas moi j'ai jamais j'ai pas de
gardes du corps et des choses comme ça
moi je crois en l'insolence de la
non-violence et donc je m'approche des
gens et même quand j'étais à l'aamm je
dis bonjour
et c'est vrai que les types ils
voulaient me casser la figure et en même
temps il était complètement étonné qu'un
type d'image bien on discute et moi je
suis c'est vrai il faut discuter gandhi
c'était très impressionnant avec parce
que justement il était face à mma il
était prêt à lâcher quoi c'était assez
serré précédemment senior chez pas là
j'hésite encore mais j'ai encore une
émission avec lui et faisait partie des
possibles il fait partie des séquelles
pour vous inscrire à voter pour daniel
mais ce qu'on a le droit de s'inscrire
encore non c'est juste que jusqu'à
scandaleux non mais c'est l'organisation
administrative que je ne mangeais vous
dire quand vous serez président la
république on pourra s'inscrire quand on
veut
les élections comme tiberi même ceux qui
sont pas bons mais bien les morts tout
le monde est bon alors là on rigole
honnêtement forman devenant pourquoi je
veux me dit moi c'est que vous êtes
passé de 9% à 5%
daniel dans les années à chantonnay ce
qu'on peut quand même sur un sentier de
ce sondage était un sauvetage bis
bizarre c'était un sondage sofres et il
ya d'autres sondages on est entre 7 et
8% et à trois quatre mois des élections
c'est vrai que les 6es problème d'image
etc
mais le sondage de 5% est bizarre parce
que le mdc était à 4%
oui un ami dont deux dans le parti donc
je veux dire mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
une forêt c'était le romantisme et est
allé dany revient merci c'est bien et
puis après bon on se pose des questions
on est pour lui pour l'europe mais pas
tout à fait pour lui sur le nucléaire on
épure lui sur le écologisme quand même
sur l'europe il va loin
donc il faut que les jeunes les choses
se clarifient est ce que dans la
campagne se méfier des bruits de
chiottes surtout pour quelqu'un comme
lui qui est contre la chasse et pour les
sans papiers
ça c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
votre nouveau avant le slogan c'était ce
n'est qu'un début continuons le combat
et maintenant c'est ce n'est qu'un début
continuons le débat est ce que vous avez
pas peur de ce côté médiateur par
opposition au côté provocateur qui votre
image est ce que c'est alors ça vous
coûte des voix finalement c'est à ce
côté vouloir fédérer le plus grand
nombre de gens est-ce que vous avez pas
peur ça vous coûte des voix c'est ça le
problème aujourd'hui vraie question mais
je crois qu'aujourd'hui dans une société
bloquée angoissé comme la nôtre en
france le débat est une provocation
la preuve c'est que les gens n'ont peur
de dire une campagne électorale c'est
pas que chacun aille dans son préau
prêcher pour sa chapelle
bon moi j'ai 800 700 900 personnes dans
un dans des meetings je leur dis vive
les verts ils disent bien sûr n'est là
pour ça hein ça serait bien plus
intéressant qu'on fasse des meetings
monsieur pasqua et moi monsieur seguin
et moi monsieur hollande et monsieur
seguin donc qu'il y ait un enjeu dans un
meeting politique au lieu de racht sera
ramassé les mêmes histoires non mais je
veux dire par rapport à arlette
laguiller comme elle reste est pure et
dure à relaxer
oui mais c'est une secte - choisir un
c'est une secte à l'amp est avec les
rejetons le le truc moi - par exemple
celui qui reste est pure et dure où je
suis pas d'accord mais j'étais pas
d'accord avec lui à 30 ans je suis pas
d'accès c'est alain krivine
c'est vrai que lui il a une pile à une
organisation qui c'est pour ça que le
pacs arlette
cela me paraît pas un pacs disons ce
n'est pas le dax honnête dans le sens
que ces deux de deux sens de la
politique c'est lorsqu'il dit vous
krivine we did et des méchants ce nom il
dit que le talent gâché
oui mais je serai mais lui c'est quel
talent qui n'a pas su se mettre au
service d'une vraie politique réformiste
votre programme est assez hard et soft
attendait le rmi pour tous les gens
jusqu'à 25 ans laurent barat socialiste
is aussi l'europe fédérale seule je dis
pas que je suis contre encore une fois
que c'est pas bien mais l'europe
fédéraliste de tout seul à le dire quoi
on voit bien qu'on va vers ça non rien
même l'ami berrou qui essayent de temps
en temps dit moi aussi je suis pour
ouais c'était un bon il faut lui il faut
le dire il faut être sympa avec ceux qui
essayent d'avoir des idées
bon et alors on en arrive bien fait le
bégaiement de beroun et autres massages
effet pas à fait pas plaindre
ben attallah c'est pour toi d'attaqués
physiques princesse oui donc notre ami
daniel et pour la légalisation du
cannabis
et ben moi nous parce que légaliser
quelque chose qui quand même une drogue
pour le savoir je suis pour la divine et
moi je sais mais la nation je suis pour
une nouvelle réglementation ainsi voilà
on est d'accord les faire cesser une
régulation c'est une règlement il faut
il faut pas jouer sur les mots quels
savoirs tendent le monument oui d'accord
mais quand on la négo direct qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire du reggae sans fumée de
pétards non mais bien sûr avant les gens
qui font du ring oui mais il ya plein de
gens qui fument des pétards et qui font
pas de règle d'or c'est vrai que écoute
écouter du reggae et voûtée du reggae en
ayant fumé
c'est aussi bien que de bien manger en
buvant un verre de vin mais justement
c'est bon ça va chacun l'avantagé entre
bernard et moi c'est que moi je suis pas
ministre mais parfois un an et donc je
l' ai dit tout à l'heure il n'y a aucun
problème
le cannabis fait partie maintenant de la
culture de jouissance en europe
on aime ou n'aime pas si on mange bien
on doit bien boire le problème c'est il
ne faut pas conduire et boire il ne faut
pas fumer et conduire super rebelle
quand même pas laisser passer ça vient
oh
[Musique]
et
je suis inquiet pour thème la nuit parce
qu'il n'a pas eue on a pu le voir vous
auriez vous présenter aux européennes
vous vous croyez avoir gros changements
ça fait même à bas coûts et manque de
soutien merci eric schmidt envoie
arielle dombasle quand je dis quand on
vous dit quand on vous dit que vous êtes
un petit peu trop sophistiqué et
effectivement je suis né sophistiqué
mais j'apprends au naturel j'ai dit ça
ouais peut-être alors mais c'est normal
que vous soyez né sophistiqués pour pour
tout un tas de raisons d'abord parce que
vous êtes la petite fille de
l'ambassadeur et ça c'est vrai que c'est
quand même un peu la route ricard a cédé
soirée l'ambassadeur bon alors ensuite
vous appelez sonnerie de fromental là
aussi c'est quand même un peu la haute
quoi ariel sonnerie de fromental h et
c'est génial dommage d'avoir enlevé
parce que sonnerie c'est joli c'est
mieux qu'une cloche 60 ans dans un corps
de fille rahim dites vous franchement
ensuite vous êtes né au mexique vous
quand vous êtes arrivé à paris vous avez
été élevé par des vieilles dames très
chic comme ça et donc voilà c'est pour
ça que vous êtes comme ça en fait et
enfin des vieilles dames il s'agit
surtout de ma grand-mère où il adore et
qui avait en effet 60 ans de plus que
moi et c'est vrai que j'ai toujours eu
une tendresse infinie pour les gens
beaucoup plus âgées et notamment pour
les vieux et le chant c'est vrai que les
grands mères sont souvent plus âgés que
nous y voilà où là bas je vous la france
ce soir découvrez ce soir voir une grand
mère s'appelait rend hommage à ma
grand-mère et à toutes les grands mères
de france car les gens âgés sont souvent
les grands oubliés des sociétés c'est
vrai
c'est pour moi le message c'est pour ça
que je dis bien vient donc ariel vous
arrivez du cinéma parce que vous avez vu
plein de films pour votre jury vous êtes
présidente alors il faut dire des
présidente du jury de la 13e édition des
acteurs à l'écran c'est ça voilà les
acteurs à l'écran à saint denis a choqué
alors je me répète mais je veux dire que
tout de même saint denis
ce n'est pas une banlieue c'est la
capitale du monde quatre milliards et
demi de gens ont eu les yeux braqués sur
saint denis
ça donne et c'est une ville formidable
et saint denis c'est une ville
culturellement formidable et samedi à
paris la première chose mais bon c'est
la russa ils ont raison et laure saint
denis c'est le saint décapité bien sûr
on peut le voir aussi d'ailleurs
il est à gauche dans notre dame on voit
le asséché calage d'états d'âme à la
celui-ci savait déjà mais sont pas des
cas alors il est bouillant j'ai jamais
vu comme ça aucune
alors dites moi donc ça à chaque fois je
donc alors vous êtes présidente du jury
un voile à travers le film à penser donc
28 mars envoyé plein de films dans les
films on est obligé paris mais je vous
assure qu'on les voit avec joie d'abord
parce qu'on n'est pas seul
c'est un festival quand même très très
ouvert puisque pour 100 francs
on peut voir 100 films plus la nuit du
court métrage etc c'est vraiment d'une
gaieté c'est une fête c'est le grand
stade qui continue il faut le dire même
si vous habitez marseille pour seulement
100 francs or et argent des crimes à
saint denis 2 part ça il ya deux prix
qui vont à distribuer le prix musidora
voilà le prix musique d'or qui
récompensent quoi qui qui récompense les
meilleurs jeunes acteurs de l'année le
prix niel et le prix michel simon s'est
donc les longs métrages et ce sont en
effet les acteurs qui viennent d'éclore
parce que c'est simplement premier ou
deuxième clip s'est propagée dans cette
émission ils font ça fait deux blondes
ce soir sont super bons moments passés
avec les review maintenant vous devez
pas y voir où ça fait mal alors que pas
du tout dites-moi arielle dombasle
vous avez une carrière éclectique est-ce
que c'est passé de romer à maya me weiss
enfin en français on dit deux flics à
miami laurent je vous le dis les
américains avait dit à l'époque de miami
vice vous est l'animal le plus sexy que
la france nous est donné depuis brigitte
bardot les amériques
ah oui c'est vrai elle est sous l effet
s'explique avant oui franchement parce
que pendant un temps elle était l'auteur
oui voilà et perceval le gallois est un
peu froide un peu on avait un bloc de
glace mais vous savez quoi vous voulez
tout ces jeunes confondus bernard henri
lévy avec paul emile victor moi c'est
vous dire mais paulo 8 ans et l'himalaya
où c'est l'everest
l'iceberg il a tout fait ouais c'est
toutes les glaces dans ce que vous êtes
devenir populairejean vous dire quand je
vous dire comment ariel comment je vais
été acceptée par les français parce que
c'est vrai que maintenant ils vous
aiment vraiment jamais vu autre entrée
non mais s'il suffit pas vous les aimiez
maintenant eux et quand vous êtes
rentrée c'est quand vous avez fait les
deux papa et la maman avec smaïn et
antoine de caunes et l'indien dans la
vie surtout lundi à ton avis l'indien
dans la vie de celle qu'ils avaient
gagné une popularité normes mais je vais
le dire tant sont envoyés des fossés des
pyramides bleues oui les pyramides le
soixante mille entrées connaissent à
60000 personnes qui se déplacent pour
voir un film et moi j'étais rami béria
sur quatre personnes entendues dans ses
consignes vraiment d'avis qu'on parlait
pas de vie film de bernard henri lévy
attendez attendez donc dans ce qu'il
faut dire aux gens si vous avez
l'occasion de voir les pyramides bleues
ça fera plaisir à arielle dombasle élevé
alors surtout il ya une flagellation
érotique dans un couvent danse finira à
ben oui parce que ariel a compris un
truc c'est que la vraie sensualité ce
qu'une phrase de vous laverez sensualité
c'est l'asservissement volonté à l'homme
qu'on aime
ah oui française après quoi la vraie
sensualité en faillite et celle
asservissement à l'homme quand même moi
j'ai dit assujettis oublie pas question
à bord on va être servi vaud
parce que je veux c'est me plaindre
alors se dire oui moi je dis non
ouais près j'ai dit oui mais au bout
d'un moment tu tu peux les schémas
classiques
bon va passer on va passer
chers amis chers ennemis nous allons
passer aux choses sérieuses
vous êtes prête mais oui alors valoir
quelque chose de bien à magnéto
[Applaudissements]
voilà voilà
c'est son mariage avec cannes non c est
qu on a dit on a dit de vous que vous
ressemblez une poupée barbie en plus
figé ce qui est pas vrai quand on vous
voit maintenant mais en revanche c'est
la chaîne on a reconnu oui oui oui
j'aimerais je n'ai jamais eu la poupée
mannequin avant vous l'a pas offerts
n'ont pas vraiment ses deux petits
garçons à qui on a fait des barbies rien
du tout ça et vous mord moi non monsieur
la maison mais vous aimiez quoi vous les
petites voitures vont broum broum broum
voilà donc j'avais des petites voitures
vroum vroum voilà après six ans
d'attenté vous avez attendu de vous
marier pendant six ans à l'époque on
s'est connus vous ne disiez pas
d'ailleurs le nom de votre fiancée je
m'en souviens très bien
et moi je le disais mais pas vous j'ai
toujours été très discret à la télé moi
est alors passé pas si mal son fiancé ne
sais pas si je les ai vus dans astérix
était sim et vous avez dit la fidélité
et voluptueuse
ah bah évidemment cette cristallisation
comme ça oui
vous n'êtes pas d'accord c'est une vertu
cela correspondait tous d'accord je vais
gagner l'autre combat ça y est on est
persuadé qu'ils goûtaient première
rencontre avec bernard henri lévy donc
vu fait dédicacer un livre vous avez 18
ans et lui il écrit donc tout ça c'est
très vraiment et je dis ça parce que
c'est la céleste patron qui commença à
ruelle il a fallu travailler la pâte
moins que ça va il écrit j'ai vu
regrette avait il écrit à ariel en
attendant et vous vous dites je suis
foudroyé je suis en transe il représente
il incarne la figure du prince c'est
très beau leur histoire aussi intéressé
je vous dis ça c'est que c'est ça vous
voulez aussi
non lui quand il va voir ariane bernard
henri lévy quand il va vous voir dans la
petite catherine de heilbronn il est
frappé l'île et chavirer c'est tellement
fort qu'il est un moment il dit je suis
épouvante
il propose 2 5x et dit non je garde mon
arrêt
et le baril le baril qui lave plus blanc
que blanc
et oui je sais faire ça parce que la
prendre c'est après la poutre ces
nantais loi je termine avec mon histoire
donc un jour vous arrivez font des sauts
et ce racisme parce que c'est pas
n'importe qui hivernent henri lévy ils
font des sos racisme et marek halter et
à la même heure vous avez rendez vous
avec lui oui et vous voyons qu'il arrive
nous voyons qu'il arrive pas au rendez
vous secret enfoncé au lutétia vous
asseyez au première fois l'art et vous
le regardez comme ça et vous êtes plus
jamais quittés voilà c'est déjà très
bien et je fais mes histoires d'amour
que les phrases et les gars la danse
amériques de détente
je serai je serai stéphane bern et
frédéric mitterrand je m'inquiéterais ce
soir ça très bien
non mais elle sera si c'était quand même
quelque chose que je tue pas
heureusement non vraiment c'est pour
dire s'il a jamais eu des tirs et que
saint denis et que la programmation des
films à saint denis et basse est tous
dans le même mois est ce que bernard
éléments vous a aidé est ce que bernard
henri lévy vous a aidé à résoudre votre
problème du bac au bac on vous a posé
comme question j'avoue j'ai toujours pas
compris
vouloir vraiment c'est vouloir ce qu'on
ne veut pas ça veut dire quoi ce truc
assez difficile attendait metella celle
là parce que valoir vouloir vraiment
c'est vouloir ce qu'on ne veut pas et
oui mais il faut voilà bon berger
je vais passer iberia vous non
sérieusement il est capable de répondre
à une question
quant à moi évidemment au bac j'ai un
petit peu triché j'ai eu de très très
bonnes chances que vous avez ce soit
fait tuer quelqu'un qui accepte et de
papier vous laisser copier donc bien
arriver que j'étais cuit depuis donc
nous n d'années alors je n'ai rien en
commun ce qui est absolument
extraordinaire vous aimez palais vous
adorez les chats veaux étaient ce les
chats vous adorez la musique
il déteste la musique en politique en 95
et soutenu balladur oui lui enfin s'il
est alors les gens c'est vous dire trois
mots pour le journal le monde
pourquoi j'ai dit qu'il avait l'esprit
voltairien ah bah oui c'est le soutenir
c'est vrai compliment si peux vous dire
et alors vous vous dites de jospin que
sa pensée poivre et sel vous plaît pas
vraiment ça doit faire de la peine à
bernard poivre et sel c'est pas mal pour
jospin pensée poivre et sel dans un sens
c'est comme si on disait de cohn bendit
qu'il a une pensée route
ah oui c'est trop il y alors voilà s'y
trouvent
non vraiment c'est vouloir ce qu'on ne
veut pas non mais ça ne trouverez pas
moi ça fait huit jours que je cherche je
ne comprends pas je vais j'ai trouvé bon
ben si quelqu'un comprend il peut nous
écrire donc ce n'est pas plus facile
maintenant non
le pape par exemple le pape oui que nous
aimons beaucoup tous les deux le pape
j'aime beaucoup le paddock seulement
parce que j'ai pas dire que ma dépouille
n'arrive à côté de sa photo chez moi il
ya celle du paf alors entendu la chanson
du pape elle est géniale
ça c'est pas qui est ce parce qu'il a
fait de mieux avec la danse qui va avec
la parkinson
si tu vends mon côté musée nan l'enfer
laurent ne vous plaignez pas vous
brûlerez en bas je serai au milieu du
miel les filles jouent là ça va faire
est trop chaud en manga bien vous serez
en enfer ça c'est sûr anthony qu'est ce
que tu vas pas un instant tu pourrais
pas si tu vas par le faire tu pourras
pas fumer explique parce qu'il y aura
pas de ce nouveau paradis a pas de
pétard mes gâteaux ou les désirs santé
en voilà c'est un enfer où c'est la
damnation ce qu ariel plus carrière l'a
compris dans tous les cas c'est qu'elle
a besoin de la parole du pape pour
pouvoir la transgresser greffon pour
vous ai compris la fonction érotique de
la religion catholique oui en fait j'ai
raccroché enfin j'ai compris beaucoup de
choses avec la religion catholique vous
savez je suis quand même d'un pays très
catholique
le mexique le mexique le ciment social
de la population et pas l'opium du
peuple c'est le catholicisme et moi j'ai
été catholique parce que quand je suis
entré dans les églises mexicaine il y
avait des champs il y avait de la
dévotion
il y avait quelque chose de transcendant
on avait l'impression de rejoindre fois
que j'avais un crucifix j'ai pleuré
oui c'est vrai bon caen 17e de
maltraiter un vendredi et tant mieux
parce que maintenant c'est beaucoup
moins drôle un désaccord entre nous on
est des deux derniers mois la légère
c'est vrai que les psaumes c'est vrai
que ce qui a été fait au nom de l'église
c'est tout même ce qui est plus beau les
cantiques les requiem toute la peinture
de vermeer discussion voilà c'est au nom
de dieu alors les problèmes avec bhl
maintenant mais c'est très court un
banquet du théâtre le jugement
nier ou c'est là vous aurez à vous et
votre amour d'ailleurs c'est parce que
c'était marqué sur le fronton donc là
plus personne pour ester au fronton de
l'atelier j'avais écrite
arielle dombasle dans une pièce de
bernard henri lévy bhl voilà après le
jour et la nuit le fameux film dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure que vous avez
vous l'avez vous déjà vu un oui les gens
faisaient la queue pour sortir ou seb à
paris sur les champs dites moi que
j'aille les tabasser j'ai réfléchi au
problème du bac c'est celle qu'on veut
pas alors après donc maintenant ce qu'il
a très bien réussi c'est sa
médiatisation et pourtant vous étiez
content moi je me souviens d'une fois où
on s'est rencontré au shéhérazade tous
les moins il y avait quelques caméras
bon enfant on avait la même intimité que
ce soit retirée on va regarder non ça va
rester encore un peu
donc c'est que je n'ai pas changé d'avis
je suis ce que regardent ouargla j'en ai
apporté qu'un mais des ddd paris match
on vous a vu il ya eu plein oui mais
enfin on m'a vue oui mais je ne pose
jamais avec bernard-henri est ce que moi
je t'ai vu tu sait dans quoi donc en
tout cas ce nom mais maintenant j'ai le
dos le solidarité
en plus c'est une super chanteuse marie
dans gala et tu montres et à mesure et
oui mais ça avait été non non non non
c'est décidé vous devez absolument des
images volées
oui absolument et match aussi celles qui
ont été dans machete mais l'on peut
jamais savoir
non alors que de toute façon on peut
l'appeler ben non il le dit lui-même
d'ailleurs même bouni et là vous dites
j'ai jamais posé c'était des photos
volées dans gala etc
ces dépenses j'ai posé quand on la fait
vivre ensemble oui
lui m'a midi dans comédie son dernier
bouquin qui est plutôt un bon bouquin
d'ailleurs qui n'a pas été assez lucide
et parle de lui alors il y parle de lui
dit je vais essayer de bien interpréter
aide moi je leur ai dit ce cabot ce
robot cet imprécateur pantine ise par
les télés emmagasinée par la presse
pipole ce philosophe sur papier glacé
je le trouve plus pathétique qu'odieux
lui qui parle de lui mais bien sûr parce
que vous savez comment a été écrit ce
lycée quand même plusieurs personnages
qui se répondent les uns les autres il a
écrit mais il ya la marionnette qui
répond il essaie d'être la marionnette
ses rapports avec l'image on a tous des
rapports plus ou moins bon avec l'image
qu'on a week est souvent loin de ce
qu'on est
alors voilà ce livre c'était un peu en
beaucoup mieux ça je veux bien mais bien
tout cas mais voilà ça c'est voilà à ben
alaoui bin il y avait des photographes à
un jour du mariage
à moins de les tabasser parce qu'il y en
a qui tabasse le jour du maire ça fait
quand même des anges et bois alors y
agence photo mais je vais écouter moi
c'était 2 mais tout à fait pour moi
aussi votre mariage
genève est la femme te regarde bon alors
non voilà quoi donc
alors on va terminer parce qu'on peut
pas non plus passer la soirée là dessus
alors derrière vous je montre un
document voilà les passants aux
documents comme ça
[Musique]
c
les
ce n'était pas facile
avec soin
là
je suis mort
c'est joli non merci
à nos amis téléspectateurs c'est donc il
ya un bel ce que les belges sont les
derniers surréaliste dernier burlesque
qui s'appelle noël godin alias le
gloupier oui mais attendez je j'aimerais
juste interveniez vous allez intervenir
j'espère qu'aux gens mais moi j'ai tenu
qu'à madame parce que sinon on ne
connaît pas qui a donc jette des tartes
à la crème sur les sur les gens connus
alors il ya eu sarkozy ou bill gates
élus patrick bruel il ppda il ya eu deux
camps du plantier il ya eu ce grand gars
j'en ai bien non ils évitent voilà je
dis ça parce que quand on pense pas que
ce soit un attentat pâtissier et ça nous
arrive de recevoir des tartes nous aussi
[Musique]
on fait l'interview quand on fait
l'interview on met les gens on n'aimait
pas longueur de bras après vous après
5,7 la bon vous avez dit bernard henry a
contracté une maladie de peau suite à
l'entartrage non je n'ai pas dit ça je
pense que ce que j'ai dit c'est que ce
fameux entarter comprend pour le verdier
entarter dernier des surréalistes est un
bon petit marchand qui vend ses photos
des gens encartés qui a tout son petit
réseau parce qu'il n'est jamais seul
et que sa photo il la vend à 40 40 mille
francs à paris match soixante mille
francs à voici et aux télévisions etc et
que c'est un petit commerce et que je
n'ai pas envie de faire fructifier ce
petit commerce de ce monsieur gobain ou
gaulle 1 et d'un peu de crème ça peut
être très très drôle mais quand ça
devient un peu tête en l'air
c'est un peu répétitif c'est vrai oui
vous êtes bonne et les faire de la
politique
le public applaudit qu ils applaudissent
tous mais si seulement ils arrivés là et
qui reprenait un d'entre nous on
rigolerait bien ouais ouais ça m'est
arrivé dans cette émission et le
lendemain il a entarté elkabbach qui a
cru que c'est moi qui ai fait mettre la
table on dirait de france 2 alors je
vais le dire gentiment chemin c'était
pas mal mais vous êtes toujours là ouais
je suis revenue pas lui bon alors on
continue alors vous savez ce qu'il a dit
le blue pied voilà il a dit si bernard
henri lévy chante le nouveau le joli
chapeau de zozo oui je connais chantelle
non non il a dit si bernard henri lévy
les chambres j'arrêterai de land'art
t'es bon moi je lui au téléphone il m'a
dit si ariel le chante j'arrête
ouais mais je ne le connais pas je n'ai
pas l'air chiant donné voilà année -
mais alors le dos les paroles on va vous
donner parole comme ça ça sera fini il
m'a promis il m'a dit c'est après demain
moi je veux pas rentrer dans sa danse à
crétinerie mais non c'est vous en foutez
vous chantez rhétorique marielle
et regardez toujours france 2 voici à
nouveau karaoké avec arielle dombasle
réel c'est samedi soir même temps donc
si vous chantez avez vous vu le nouveau
chapeau de zozo c'est un chapeau un
chapeau rigolo il ne l'emportera plus
jamais ne le faut pas pourquoi si vous
rentrez dont j'apporterai sont d'accord
c'est pas tous merci eric 1 mais le mec
il lit les emmerdes
israël va pas en plus de toi je n'ai pas
tant prôné la crainte au bond non mais
c'est écouter voilà on va chanter we do
attention ce serait dommage
josé et attendez moi je suis passé voir
sa cellule et kabok de nantir ces
paroles de bernard henri lévy vous
connaissez rien on vous écoute avez vous
vu le nouveau châssis
voilà un mois je suis là pour ça
[Rires]
avez vous vu le chapeau 2 au sol et à
charbon et de l acier la chanson qui est
génial vouloir vraiment c'est vouloir ce
qu'on ne veut pas c'est les mêmes
paroles en boucle donc ariel on est bien
d'accord
ce soit leur maire bernard henri lévy
n'est pas à l'abri de se faire en tarte
et encore elle avait refusé de sauver
bernard ans et les personnes autour de
cette table je vous dis le petit
commerce continue on va pas l'arrêter
donc alors on vous retrouve à saint
denis tous les genoux ça oui le nombril
démons et atomique
c'est très à la mode et non il alors on
va passer à la suite
c'est une brique mais une question à
poser arielle dombasle
non je lui souhaite bonne chance et
qu'elle continue à nos enfants enchantés
omh america toi aussi n'a pas été
d'ailleurs il y aurait pu moi je chante
parce que chapeau 2 aux sages comprend
que de savoie ouais mais ça vous pouvez
pas dire non alors voilà un truc très
beau comme vous faites la bac baroque
non mais c'est par une chose tout nous
tue bronzer
le papa your own et papaye ou puissiez
vous le faites bien de papayou papayou
le papayou papageno oui oui nos âmes et
voilà
et donc nous accueillons
elle m'a demandé est ce que vous allez
chanter le joli chapeau deux zozos non
va-t-on de l'enfant quand même pour
l'entente ensuite je suis effondré on
m'avait dit cette émission sérieuse
vraiment ravi le service public tu
verras bon alors erwann menthéour vous
allez écrire un livre qui s'appelle
secret défonce jaune a beau jeu de mots
dirait maître capello c'est publié chez
lattès vous avez décidé d'écrire ce
livre quand vous avez rendu visite
un de vos anciens coéquipiers qui
avaient un cancer des testicules pour
vous dire en face à ses potes ça c'est
pas décider exactement là ouais enfin ça
a aidé à votre d'électrochoc
ce livre s'est vendu en quatre semaines
à 80 mille exemplaires donc c'est pour
dire quelque chose dans le bouquin parce
que vous n'êtes pas un auteur très connu
faut bien le dire
beaucoup moins connu bernard henri lévy
oui je peux dire en même temps votre
livre se vend à 80 mille exemplaires en
quatre semaines 1 c'est numéro un des
ventes
il faut dire qu'il ya de la coque à
l'intérieur il ya pas mal de dos belon
et il ya eu des points comme c'est très
étonnant que celui ce qui vous arrive et
eu des pointes à 6000 exemplaires par
jour
ouais non mais j'en ai bien conscience
j'en avais conscience et après son
passage dans l'émission à france inter
donc est ce que l'équipe en a parlé de
votre bouquin est ce que le journal
l'équipe en a parlé oui si oui ils en
ont parlé parce que
ils ont eu peur que le canard en parle
avant avant tout parce qu'il voulait pas
réagir là-dessus et donc ils ont
interprété mon comportement en disant
que j'étais mégalo l'umih tôt que
j'avais jamais été un bon coureur en
fait que j'étais le tocard accès erwann
menthéour qui a inventé le dopage en
fait la k way mais en même temps c'est
un peu compréhensible qu'ils vous aiment
pas trop parce que le groupe qui possède
le journal l'équipe et possède le tour
de france groupe amaury alors vous dites
service pendant ce bouquin je me suis
mis à poil pour pour découvrir les
coulisses du cyclisme et vous dites si
pour qu'on découvre les causes du
cyclisme c'est d'une démarche purement
égoïste et une histoire de d'évacuer
quelque chose de faire la paix avec moi
même si on la présente d'une manière
psychanalytique c'est il ya deux phrases
de vous qui sont je vais pas les
interpréter je vois sur il ya deux
phrases de vous qui sont si j'avais lu
ce livre à 15 ans j'aurais jamais fait
de compet ça c'est une phrase de bien
j'ai bien fait du mal
et alors il ya une autre phrase de vous
qui 10 à 20 ans si on m'avait dit si tu
bois un litre de gasoil gagnera le tour
de france j'en aurai plus deux pour en
gagner deux ouais voilà deux phrases qui
ce qui s'oppose
aujourd'hui c'est quoi votre état
d'esprit mon état d'esprit par rapport
au dopage
ouais non pas par rapport au dopage par
rapport à ça attire d'un côté vous étiez
prêts à tout pour être champion et
l'autre côté en fait quand vous avez vu
ce que c'était champions vous avez envie
de le faire passer ça comme ta phrase
vous là vraiment c'est vouloir ce qu'on
ne veut pas voilà l'explication expliqué
pas rentrer là-dedans d'or fils de la
prévenue
bon alors votre carrière commence le 12
juillet 1984 quand votre frère père
henri menthéour gagner l'étape du tour
de france vous avez 11 ans vous décidez
de champion et elle se termine par une
double fracture du poignet quand vous
aviez de maillot jaune dans le tour de
l'avenir voilà alors on va parler de
vous en parler de votre bouquin de les
voir c'est moi honnêtement alors
sérieusement
j'étais scotché par ce bouquin parce que
j'en ai lu des trucs on en a eu un
bouquin rive droite aussi j'ai écrit un
bouquin sur la dope
mais qui est beaucoup moins grave que
mohammed était intéressant que nous
tiens alors ses valises de junkie
d'ailleurs c'est d'observer ce que c'est
les junkies ou des crises et des gens
qui sont des piqûres d'héroïne c'est un
livre de junkie c'est à dire qu'il ya à
la fois la drogue
enfin là c'est le dopage disparue
l'omniprésent way et puis une espèce de
routine la drogue fait partie de la vie
quotidienne c'est vers une des exigences
silence drogue comme ça il ya une espèce
pas de bonne humeur on prend ça avec un
certaine ce qu'il faut que tu saches
dans le sport en particulier dans le
cyclisme c'est culturel le dopage
oui c'est à dire que c'est complètement
désacraliser voilà dès qu'il pleut
déculpabilisation collective
elle ne fait que satisfaire l'exigence
de junkie qu'il souhaite donner ensemble
c'est normal attentes et que tu es gamin
tu as un chemin initiatique pour y
arriver en temps doctrine déculpabilise
c'est normal c'est pose même pas la
question n'a même pas l'impression de
tricher tes impressions de te soigner
seulement non mais moi moi je suis
halluciné
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure je suis halluciné que les autres
que tout d'un coup maintenant sa phase 1
enfin je sais pas moi j'ai depuis que je
suis tout môme je sais que les mecs du
co2 à moi j'ai du tour de saxe était
était bâchée page sur d'or tous les
temps dans le lait sur le temps qui me
dérange quand tu te dis fait le seul
mais le mythe du tour de france non non
non non mais cela en général sport en
général oui il ya beaucoup de pognon
l'arrivée massive de l'argent dans le
sport cette dernière qui sont priés d'en
parler mais par exemple
jour vous êtes vous arrêter entre deux
arbres j'avais votre petit il appelle
sincèrement et j'appelle ça une
fléchette les petites fléchettes dans la
pologne chine envoie dans le sang une
petite piqûre dans le film typique
heures dans les po lire part au tour
suivant mais c'est naturel une petite
fille par exemple
vous dites aussi que ils se font des
piqûres avec de l'eau pour le plaisir du
geste et ç'a été détruits contre il ya
des mecs qui en soit cette dérive soit
sachez aussi à utiliser ces gens qui se
font des piqûres avec de l'eau parce
qu'ils n'ont rien d'autre
mais pour le plaisir de la pic alors
qu'un bond bidon et dramé c'était c'est
incroyable ce bouquin je comprends que
tout le monde je crois qu'il ya une
espèce de bonne humeur
expliquez-nous vous allez expliquer ça
veut dire avec ton temps et tintin pour
lui d'aller faire rire y chez mémé que
ça leur passe navigo explique bâton
c'est le ton et dont le tenez de
renseignements c'est ta mine ça c'est de
méthamphétamine bad je crois tentons
tintin c'est le père vite un loris néry
d'ailleurs comment c'est la ritaline les
kamis des kamikazes japonais prenez de
la ritaline pour s'écraser que le
sourire sur les haies sur les
porte-avions à harceler la mémé c'est
l'âme et edwin donc si tu veux tu prends
ça t'a déjà goûté un petit peu il ya
longtemps et l'entente mais si tu prends
un cocktail là je dire tu es le plus
beau le plus fort le plus intelligente
et invincible loi qui a longtemps
c'est vrai que j'ai lu ce bouquin je me
dis le vélo finalement alors bon
voilà voilà l'exemple même avec tonton
est un tas on est allé faire irish et
d'aimer ça veut dire qu'on s'est envoyé
à peu près tout ce qui existe comme en
fait juste pour le sport pour le sport
ça avec ça c'est une autonomie de
combien parce qu'on voit les attend faut
quand même faire une précision pendant
le tour de france on prend pas ça oui
c'est le dopage c'est le dopage bonne
franquette qui tu veux c'est le plaisir
certitude si tu l'as pas si je peux la
prendre une manière toxicomaniaque on
aime bien ça on aime bien ça est
d'accord c'est alors que comme tu fumes
un gros pétard ou tu vas te faire un
rail qui va dire ben oui mais il aime ça
mais non la ferme du petit dopage 36 à 7
dopage sympa parce qu'on arrivait de
trucs terribles c'est le dopage issus du
génie génétique
allégorie plus grave il ya les
corticoïdes bon ça on meurt pas les en
fait comme ça non non mais je n'avais
j'imagine que ça nourrit le muscle
gossas dois t'arrêter cardinal
émotionnel
il n'y a aucune raison pour effacer ça
fait pas plus stupide avec le cnr quoi
si ces gars y as tu veux le dire hier
pendant toute l'émission puis là on
parle de dobby là on a l'impression d'un
seul coup d'avoir un vélo entre les
jambes
bon alors on continue
moi j'ai lu le bouquin et honnêtement
j'ai deux trois trucs que je voudrais
dire quand même dingue parce que c'est
vraiment fou on les corticoïdes bon les
corticoïdes s'il connaît la corse donne
on connaît il ya le pays haut alors le
pays au ca augmente les globules rouges
dans le sang ça améliore l'oxygénation
du sang
et alors ce que j'ai lu dans ce bouquin
c'est à quoi même si je l'avais vu aux
guignols
quand il se foutait de la gueule de
virac mais je croyais pas que c'était
vrai c'est que les mecs ils sont
tellement ils ont pris ces trucs là que
la nuit ils sont obligés de faire des
pompes pour pas que le sens cohérent le
sas et on en a parlé s'il paraît que
c'est vraiment arrivé
mais depuis depuis sept huit ans on a
déjà des montres cardiaque c'était très
on hématocrite de donc depuis deux ans
et que je décide alors c'est ça le sport
testeurs à vous avez pu situer descend
en dessous de 25 stations minutes savez
bip bip bip bip huîtres et vsat réveille
parce que l'augmentation dû rythme car
parce qu'ils sont obligés d'avoir des
anticoagulants et des va et vient sur la
table de nuit
c'est fou cette histoire alors il ya le
pot belge c'est qu'on sait qu'on devient
belge il va dire je ne dis rien ne dit
rien parce que le pot belge faut pas
voir ce qui attend paul badji ya jeudi
j'ai amphétamines cocaïne héroïne
antalgiques vasodilatateur corticoïdes
morphine et ça vaut entre 500 et 2000
pape sy les mecs qui font du vélo il
s'en voit ça tous les faits mais par
michel drucker j'en ai regardé les mecs
arrêtez atterrissait cinq minutes
moi je veux dire tu aurais pu faire un
livre dans le showbiz attention silence
on sniffe moi j'ai fait secret défense
sera quoi je peux dire un truc c'est
qu'à la télé les mecs non on ne savait
pas on croit explique ed en fait ouais
on a découvert ça quand il ya un petit
malin qui a pris 5 l analyse et voilà on
s'est dit [ __ ] on a compris on sait
faire retourner complètement on prenait
des en fait parce que d'abord c'est
culturel ça faisait partie de notre
boulot tu vas faire un critère tu vas
faire des critériums pendant 30 jours
après le tour de france les mecs qui
sont défoncés il a fait 30 jours ouais
ouais
et en plus ils doivent conduire la nuit
un jour tu es à toulouse le lendemain tu
es à bordeaux le lendemain tu es à paris
tu vois bon on savait pas ça et puis
d'un seul coup en fait rendu compte que
les mecs qui l'ont récupérée permettant
de la coca zéro pour rendre les mecs
accro je suis un fidèle je suis ce que
je suis ce coaching cyclisme masculin
cyclisme féminin jeannie longo 90 ans et
pédales encore il ya bien un truc alors
on va aller vite parce que voilà il faut
acheter des bouquins après tout les gens
qui ont acheté des fois par exemple on
met des blocs en turc compte un
directeur de course pactual
il tient à injecter débloquant ce qui
fait que le monde est à l'étude y arrive
pas corse et richard virenque c'est un
bêtabloquant alors les cobayes
vous êtes cobayes ont vu ce dont vous
utilisent comme cobayes avant avant même
les animaux sur un test des produits
sûrs avant même d avoir testé six
cobayes avait des chevaux et cobayes ont
des vélos et or il ya un moment terrible
en deux ans
les français de reprendre à poubelles ça
marche bien ce mot est lancé
je suis tombé dedans quand j'étais petit
bois saint félix moi c'est le pot du
havre alors non quand vous dites il
m'était poussé quelque chose qui
ressemble à un droit c'est bien c'est
que voilà c'est vrai je mens interpréter
stroganoff et moi j'avais une adoration
à celle qui s'est enquis c'est quoi une
injure raciale geste et tout et tout le
temps en train de frotter sur l'accès au
niveau de l'année il avait donné un
petit kyste qui s'est enflammée puis
c'est devenu un truc comme ça c'est donc
j'ai dit c'est qu'on aille aux élections
qui m'était pousser quoi pousser parce
qu'on m'avait foutu de la cortisone de
draguer pour les slows ça doit être
génial
bon enfin voilà donc vous serez vous
expliquer c'est malheureusement ce qu'on
comprend c'est dire qu'avec la télé les
sponsors ben voilà on est obligé de
gagner sinon dévierait et oui jamais eu
confiance elle vous dira un sport est
une course comme le tour de france où
les types vont essayer d'aller le plus
vite possible pour avoir un maillot
marqué crédit lyonnais
fabian vous n'êtes pas très à coeur
enfin on apprend quand même que lino il
a pris la tête d'une grève contre les
contrôles le mon but c'était pas de ça y
est surtout pressé je pense être parce
qu'à des [ __ ] qui sont autour qui
profite de ce que génère le cyclisme
ouais et qu'ils vont jouer les parents
dans 28 des les mêmes que jalabert mais
je peux pas bien mais tout ça sort de
nos 5 jalabert vous dites qu'il avale le
vent tout comme d'autres avalent des
religieux au café jalabert dans le tour
d'espagne fin qu'à une vache espagnole
qui a bouffé de l'herbe dans un champ où
il avait peas et elle a gagné une étape
dieu m'est témoin drôle ya le caucchioli
le gagnant du duel en deçà attention ça
c'est un truc qui possède en france soir
et je n'ai pas dit tout ce qui était dit
en français on m'a dit voilà que de
jolies idées en hémodialyse on m'a dit
benzina eu un cancer de la moelle
épinière et plusieurs mecs et le giro 95
on m'a dit ça et on m'a dit est ce que
c'est des conséquences directes du
dopage moi j'ai répondu oh mec qui a
fait l'interview du g10 attend 1 mais
qui fume deux paquets de clopes par jour
il a plus de chance de choper un cancer
des poumons qu'un mec qui fume c'est
clair et le lendemain on a dit que c'est
moi qui avais dix accords pas greg les
vendent rodriguez qu'il avait été
atteint après avoir été le le vélo de
myopathie mitochondrial non mais il y en
a une on voit la beauté officiel mais
c'est pas moi qui est ce que vous dîtes
surtout c'est qu'un jour il y en a qui
va mourir en direct c'est peut-être ce
qu'ils attendent pour comprendre qui est
vraiment un problème de fond aujourd'hui
c'est un problème s'inscrit dans une
logique qui dépasse le cadre du sikhisme
du sport c'est un problème de santé
publique
parce que si quelqu'un avait été voir
mon pote à l'hôpital ouais parce que là
on peut rigoler on peut cependant
théorie des genres soit je rigole on
rigole heureusement qu'on rigole parce
que c'est vrai que le sujet si on avait
été voir mon pote qui faisait 40 kg
alors que j'étais un playboy dessous de
76 kg 1 beaucoup et un bagel bronze et
les yeux bleus l'aurait vu sur lit
d'hôpital ça donne à réfléchir bien sûr
lorsque vous dites alors ce cas pas du
tout rassurant dans votre bouquin et
roanne c'est que c'est pareil dans tous
les sports un jour est allé chez un
doctorat en italie et là vous dites
les amateurs de records peuvent
abandonner leurs illusions parce que
vous avez vu des gens de tous les sports
et même vous dites qu'en dehors du sport
les gens qui prennent la france est le
plus grand consommateur dans garanti
quand même tranquillisants a lancé à
gragnague rap rozak etc
il viendra c'est pour être meilleur
grâce au rejet
des ruses dans tous les sports en judo
on a eu déjà mail bouras qui est venu
dire que finalement été innocenté alors
c'est un peu compliqué quand même à
savoir qui dit la vérité
vieira qui lui dit qu'il est innocent
derby dragon ne soutenait vachement vous
vous êtes très provient le discours et
les suivants ouais aujourd'hui j'ai une
question à poser aux médias un point où
est ce qu'on demande à richard viron
d'état d'intellectuels pourquoi est ce
qui devrait endosser la responsabilité
de tous le dopage qui a dans le sport
pourquoi est ce que richard qui a été un
empereur du sport français et une
virenque manier en france oui le
maintien dans la grisaille de descendre
de son piédestal alors que tous ses
concurrents directs d'hommes donc sur
leurs deux oreilles
est-ce que ça encourage les autres mecs
à parler ouais non et voilà alors
maintenant richard virenque tout le
monde se fout de sa gueule c'est super
riches à son boulot c'est d'être coureur
cycliste professionnel et je crois
qu'ils s'expriment bien sur un vélo pour
lui demander d'être un intellectuel
bon ben ça vient alors qu'à une chose
arrêter le vélo vous allez vous avez
chanté je viens de raconter que vous
arrivez dans une boîte et que vous
chantez onesta vous savez le chantier
honesty ouais je chantais tient un
passionné ch'ti et si vous cherchez une
hostilité ya pas de l art et si vous
chantez le président vous ne serez pas
embarquer ah oui entartré la gueule sur
le plat alors je précise que moi je suis
surtout en train de travailler avec
richard croc devrait s'occuper gagner
les adresse un très très bon
voilà donc maintenant le nouveau métier
defuse cheveux teints
s
[Musique]
m
les vieux locaux connaissent une
majestueuse blaye et en ethiopie
selon
wii noire et libérale et moi qu'à vélo
thierry henry n'est ce pas
ni roi
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]